واجهن عسكري واخر سياسي دبلوماسي وبالطبعه
هناك التنافس المالي المصرفي الفضائي
والنووي من اين نبدا واين ننتهي حين نتحدث
عن التنافس الامريكي الصينيه ليس فقط في
افريقيا كما كنا نقول قبل قليل العملاقاني
يتبرزان في كل المجالات تقريبا
من هذه المجالات او يترقبها ربما اخر
الساحه اخرى كبيره ليست بحر الصين
الجنوبيه
المحكوم بالكثير من الوقت والتاجيل
المدروس والتعقيدات العسكريه وجيو
السياسيه ولا حتى القاره الافريقيه التي
ذكرناها قبل قليل فساحه المعنيه تتزاحم
بارقام
لنقرب الصوره اكثر بمجهر الساعه 6:00
الحرب
التكنولوجيه وما اشرسها هو
والجيل الخامس او 5 جي عنوان عريض لنقترب
اكثر
قواعد البيانات نعم اقتربنا كثيرا
مشاهدينا نعم نتحدث عن الخصوصيه وهنا
المجال واسع ويتعلق بالسريه التي تخترقها
الصين والولايات المتحده بالجواسيس نعم
هذا نمط وهناك انماط اخرى ومنها النقره
وتخيلوا حين تتحول النقره في مساله امن
قومي